bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport nous sommes ici sur
le golf national de guyancourt pour une
mission spéciale golf tout de suite on
passe au sommaire le golf national
accueillera l'alstom open de france du 2
au 5 juillet les meilleurs joueurs
français et internationaux se
retrouveront sur les greens de 50 ans y
vivent ces trois jours de compétition
pour parler de cet événement nous
recevrons paul armitage le directeur du
golf national etc sandro réel
superintendant charge du parcours pour
ensuite un point complet sur les
ambitions et l'avenir du golf français
que jean rochât rouleau président de la
fédération et puis en fin d'émission
nous ferons un zoom complet sur la ryder
cup une compétition que le golf national
accueillera en 2018
près de soixante mille personnes sont
attendus quotidiennement à saint quentin
en yvelines pour ce grand rendez vous
international équivalent de la coupe du
monde de golf
je le disais dans les titres l'alstom
open de france de golf est programmé
dans deux semaines à saint quentin en
yvelines a les meilleurs joueurs
internationaux se retrouveront pour
cette 99e édition pour nous parler de
cet événement nous recevrons dans
quelques instants paul armitage
directeur du golf national mais
également alexandre reyes qui est en
charge du parcours
mais avant ça immersion dans les
coulisses de la préparation le montage
est signée romain respini une
cinquantaine de joueurs de haut niveau
venus des quatre coins du monde soixante
mille spectateurs sont quatre jours de
compétition la stone open de france et
le plus grand rendez-vous golfique en
france il était organisé pour la
première fois au golf national à
guyancourt en 1991 sur le site tout est
mis en place pour accueillir les
sportifs dans les meilleures conditions
les joueurs quand ils arrivent sur le
tournoi
aussi bien le premier jour que tous les
autres jours qui suivent les quatre
jours du tournoi
ils arrivent les voitures les limousines
les dépose à l'entrée là juste à cette
porte là et ils arrivent ici
ces deux bureaux là sont
occupée par le directeur du tournoi ses
collaborateurs
les secrétaires du tour ce bureau ici il
est à l'usagé exclusif des arbitres ici
on est dans le vestiaire hommes il ya le
pendant le côté pour les femmes et
pendant l'open de france c'est un
vestiaire qui réservé aux pros ici comme
les locaux au dessus c'est vraiment une
fourmilière des gens qui sont là une
fois l'année et puis c'est vrai que
c'est qu'ils s'approprient le qui
s'approprie le site pour entretenir les
140 hectares de pelouses du golf
national une vingtaine de machines est
utilisé par les 20 jardiniers du site
on est au hangar donc c'est toute la
partie entretien puis ce qu'on appelle
la partie maintenance voilà donc vous
avez les matériels les différents
matériels qu'on utilise sur le parcours
depuis les plus petits les râteaux les
pelles jusqu aux machines les plus
grosses comme les tondeuses à farewell
ici on a aussi pas mal de pulvérisateurs
qu'on utilise pour des travaux de
fertilisation enfin on a énormément de
matériel donc tout est remise est ici
pendant les mois qui précèdent les
grands événements sportifs organisés par
le golf national les jardiniers
multiplient les opérations de rénovation
objectif mettre les 45 trous du site
haut standing d'un golf de haut niveau
ont reproduit souvent les mêmes
opérations mais avec une fréquence
accrue
là par exemple cette opération là ils
vont essayer d'en passer encore à mon
avis trois voire quatre dans le mois qui
vient
le reste de l'année c'est une opération
qu'on va faire mensuellement par exemple
une attention toute particulière est
apportée au bunker la rénovation peut
durer entre un jour et une semaine en
fonction de la superficie de ces
obstacles en sable l'autre zone
importante d'un parcours de golf
ce sont les bunkers qui sont remplis de
sable et donc effectivement à la proche
de l'open il ya un gros gros travail de
nettoyage de ratissage pour expurger le
fab des cailloux et puis pour vraiment
procurez indice un très net c'est-à-dire
qu'on coupe les bordures de façon
vraiment à ce que le les bunkers
ressorte avec des arêtes vives tous les
élèves de banker on le voit bien ici et
on voit une personne n'a pas c'est
pareil qui travaillent à côté du bunker
derrière le green du 2 à deux semaines
du début des épreuves lifting annuel du
golf national est presque terminée et ne
manque plus que les joueurs le spectacle
peut commencer
nous sommes de retour ici au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
avec le directeur paul hermitage le
directeur du golf national et alejandro
reyes super attendant en charge du
parcours on l'a vu dans le reportage
tout est millimétré un vraiment pour
préparer cet open de france de golf
absolument on as pas en laisse rien au
hasard
surtout avec un champ de joueurs
magnifiques 254 joueurs les meilleurs
européens
et puis aussi une dotation qui bat qui
est le plus élevé sur le continent
européen
en dehors des tournois des îles
britanniques alejandro on voit que le
sapin ce parcours de l'albatros est l'un
des plus beaux en europe
est ce qu'ils demandent une attention
particulière oui bien sûr les tout à me
saouler tous les opérations qu'on fait
du rail ou les avec mon grain
organisation de l'équipe et une
collaboration avec l'european tous les
directeurs de tournois et le directeur
agronome de l'european tour
on travaille en équipe pour l'améliorer
du rail ou de préparer les tournants
alejandro c'est un parcours qui plaît
vraiment joueurs oui énormément
c'est un challenge et on teste pour les
duels c'est et c'est vrai que
les retours des us tournoi après tournoi
cesser son terme en quelles sont nos
réactions en général quand on termine ce
18 trous assez les rationaliser le haut
la main la belle équipe et non la région
c'est très positif et la région cv et
enfin c'est fini tu es avec les
conditions de vente qu'on peut trouver
les vins les plateaux pour les vols
nationale a été construit et et nous
pénale le tournoi c'est vrai que c'est
bling attention à les détailler à les
feedbacks l'airé tout le délégué
et voilà c'est très motivant
paul est ce qu'on peut dire que le golf
national de guyancourt et l'un des pubs
pour l'europe
oui je pense qu'on peut on peut le dire
je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention parce qu'elle est très beaux
golfs en europe en france un peu partout
mais c'est vrai que
le fait que nous avons obtenu la
fédération française de golf la france a
candidaté obtenu la ryder cup et pour
majeure partie cette candidature a gagné
grâce à la qualité du parcours à la fois
de sa jouabilité pour les joueurs là sa
difficulté mais le parcours y est pour
beaucoup donc on peut dire effectivement
que en un des plus beau car parcours si
c'est pas le plus beau d'europe et
l'open de france est programmé donc dans
deux semaines
ici à au golf national de guyancourt est
ce que les joueurs se précipitent pour
venir cet open de france est ce que
c'est un tournoi qui les intéresse dans
leur calendrier
oui pour les raisons qu'on a déjà évoqué
en entrée de démission c'est il ya une
dotation qui est riche qui est très
importante on a des vainqueurs des beaux
vainqueurs comme graeme mcdowell qui
revient cette année en a également
victor dubuisson notre numéro un
français qui a brillé l'année dernière
pour se positionner dans le top 20
mondiaux donc oui tout à fait c'est un
rendez vous incontournable sur le
calendrier à deux semaines trois
semaines de l'open britannique qui le
troisième majeur de l'année donc c'est
un bon tour d'échauffement pour pour ce
type de tournoi lesquels seront du coup
les joueurs qui seront présents cette
année
alors comme on l'a dit grammacks dalle
va venir essayer de gagner pour la
troisième année de suite les deux
présidents 2014 a écopé de 15 pour ce
cas jamais 300 pesos 3 voilà exactement
on peut faire lee westwood qui qui est
un
un vieux briscard du tour européen
revient après deux années d'absence
on peut aussi citer d'autres joueurs de
ryder cup
de l'ecosse des îles britanniques qui
vont être là donc oui on a un beau
plateau encore cette année
alejandro est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut y avoir des surprises sur cet open
de france
oui eh ben ce qu'est que oui et en fait
on les oies et n'aller score dans les
dernières quatre trous et qu'est ce
qu'on appelle le circuit final est de
l'albatros est
du gant provisoire et les scorpions
il y à trois trous avec des lots et des
personnes ou
une très longue par quatre et sa poignée
vraiment mais ouais il pourra boire des
verres surpris c est aussi et encore ça
la météo pensionnés la conduisent les
conditionner pas codé ou d'une autre et
radicale la météo est assez particulière
est ici en france est ce que ça peut
jouer du coup c'est vous pas comme
aujourd'hui avec un vent pareil pour ce
tournage cecos et un avec les greens
rapide que alejandro va préparer avec
son équipe plus les rov les rucks et les
aux herbes qui sont proches des déserts
de jeu ça peut scorer très haut revenons
aux joueurs il ya un joueur qui n'a
jamais fouler les greens de l'open de
france c'est tiger woods est ce que vous
avez essayé de l'avoir encore cette
année
est ce que vous pourriez avoir à
l'avenir alors t'en parle toujours de
tiger woods tag wood a déjà joué le golf
national dans des championnats de monde
amateur je me souviens plus dans quelle
année donc il a déjà frôlé défaire ou et
du golf national
mais depuis deux ans tiger woods
malheureusement il est dans une séquence
un petit peu moins - je dirais brillante
de sa carrière il est même passé au delà
de la centième voire 150e place mondiale
et on commence à parler d'autres
personnels personnes jeunes les nouveaux
tiger tels que rory mcilroy
donc je ne sais pas peut-être pour la
ryder cup il y as comment dire une envie
des américains de regagner cette coupe
donc l'année prochaine aux etats-unis
2016 et après la prochaine fois que
c'est en europe ce sera ici au golf
national en 2018
peut-être il y sera mais peut-être en
tant que capitaine vice-capitaine
peut-être même en tant que joueur s'il
face à un retour il est là quand même et
il n'a pas quarante ans encore donc il
peut encore revenir au plus haut niveau
dont tiger woods ici à saint quentin lui
c'est possible tout à fait tout est
possible
tout est possible surtout avec un ryder
cup avec cet open de france aussi on
s'attend ce qui est des français
peut-être qui brille sur sur cette
compétition
je pense notamment à victor dubuisson
est ce que c'est lui qui peut être le
favori des français
cette année je pense que sur la fiche de
l'open si vous l'avez vu nous avons fait
apparaître un autre joueur français qui
brille qui brille par la victoire de
tournois sur les circuits mondiaux c'est
alexandre lévy qui a essayé en début
d'année de jouer aux états unis et cette
année qui revient en forme actuellement
donc on peut regarder alexandre la vie
et on peut avoir des surprises gary stal
un lyonnais qui a gagné un tournoi
important devant rory mcilroy abou dhabi
en début d'année au mois de février mars
a déjà gagné cette année donc oui on
n'est pas l'abri et au contraire on
souhaiterait pour le public français au
moins une victoire si ce n'est que
deuxième troisième place et une finale
dimanche après midi extrêmement serré
avec un français bien sûr dans dans le
coup donc le successeur de thomas levet
peut gagner dès cette année oui les
français sans qu'ils avaient gagné en
2011 tout à fait en est en elle à
l'heure actuelle dans une période faste
pour le golf français on n'a jamais vu
ça mais on a eu trois joueurs dans le
top 100 on a et victor top-20 alexandre
lévy top 50
en et en est vraiment le golf français
est en train de prendre une ampleur
importante sur les circuits mondiaux
nous avons justement rencontré le
président de la fédération française de
golf le jean louis charon nous les avons
évoqué ensemble l'avenir et les
potentiels futurs stars du golf français
vous savez que jean-loup charron le
président de la fédération française de
golf merci nous avons accordé cet
entretien
alors nous allons faire le tour
d'horizon du golf en france où situez
vous la france par rapport aux autres
nations européennes et mondiales
aujourd'hui la france l'a connaît un
développement dans le monde du golf
assez fort et nous sommes devenus une
référence dans le monde du golf par les
actions de développement que nous avons
entrepris de plus depuis plusieurs
années de plus les résultats sportifs
qu'on enregistre chez les garçons mais
aussi chez les filles amateurs et
professionnels mettent la discipline en
avant plus la fédération avec les
projets que nous avons d'accueillir la
ryder cup en 2018 plus le retour du
boeuf aux jo en 2016
donc on eu qu un petit peu le devant de
la scène
on est ravi de la fère et disons que au
niveau européen on est parmi les pays
plutôt leader actuellement et est ce que
vous trouvez que les français remportent
à ces titres
alors les françaises et les français
brille chaque week end dans les
différentes épreuves mondiales d'antony
pour professionnels qu'amateurs et jeu
chaque titre remporté chaque podiums
conquis et à qui met un peu plus la
france et le golf en évidence alors vous
dirai ce qu'il remporta ses titres je
vais vous dire non tellement l'appétence
est forte et on aimerait que
pratiquement chaque week-end nos
françaises et non français soit premier
et il ya une nouvelle génération c'est
qui ce mec qui se met en place et victor
dubuisson notamment est ce que cette
nouvelle génération va porter le golfe
français au haut niveau encore plus
victor dubuisson est celui qui a ouvert
la porte un petit peu il a montré à tout
le monde à une jeune génération que
c'est possible en victor dubuisson avec
l'émir en demain at-elle gary stal sont
parmi ceux qui peuvent prétendre occuper
jouer les premiers rôles au niveau
mondial demain mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres edward s pana est là aussi
alors c'est toujours le danger lorsqu'on
énumère et qu'on cite les joueurs et des
joueuses cédant n'oublions donc ils
viennent richesse cayla et la france ait
les infrastructures pour les faire
progresser
oui sans aucun doute nous avons un peu
plus de 700 parcours 700 structure
graphique 734 précis il y a quelques
projets mais surtout il ya une politique
de développement du golf en france de
manière à ce qu'un plus grand nombre
puisse le pratiquer une politique liée à
la ryder cup au départ qui était de
construire des petites structures
on s'est fixé l'objectif de 100 petites
structures à l'horizon 2018
il ya une pépite qui fait beaucoup
parler d'elle en ce moment c'est
l'hygiène ou est-ce que vous la
connaissez
alors oui c'était effectivement une
jeune femme une jeune fille devrais je
dire qui a un des beaux coups de
promesses beaucoup de talent semble-t-il
et j'espère que nous le prouvera
prochainement justement il y genou a
remporté cinq titres la dernière porte
cette jeune joueuse images sont signés à
william l elie genou 18 ans est l'un des
plus grands espoirs du golf français
accros à ce sport depuis l'âge de 6 ans
ce talent brut a frappé ses premières
balles avec des clubs en plastique dans
son jardin la jeune golfeuse s'est
ensuite tourné progressivement vers le
haut niveau un choix qui a surpris ses
amis et ses parents avaient des vues
avait énormément d'à priori comme quoi
le golf est un sport de riches que c'est
que c'était un sport pour les vieux
c'est vrai qu'une fois qu'ils viennent
au golf et qu'on leur fait vraiment
découvrir le milieu et comprennent que
c'est vraiment un sport où ok c'est pas
vraiment physique mais il ya un énorme
travail mental donc ils sont assez
impressionné après après avoir vaincu
les préjugés et les genoux terrasse
maintenant ses adversaires pendant les
compétitions
la prodige licencié au racing club de
france a de moins en moins de place dans
sa chambre pour entreposer ces coupes et
ses médailles mais d'ailleurs j'ai gagné
cinq tournois dans l'année dont cinq
tournois qui était assez important qui
sont en france et où c'est un champ où
c'est tout les faits qui ont plus de 18
ans du coup que c'était vraiment une
bonne année j'ai gagné à saint cloud
dans mon club aux racines et ensuite
j'ai gagné dans le sud essentiellement à
calmer année c'est un palmarès
impressionnant que la jeune golfeuse
fans de tiger woods et de victor
dubuisson doit à sa force de caractère
et à son goût de l'effort
c'est une fille très très motivé depuis
toujours très jeune qui très opiniâtre
et qui a du coup cette qualité pour
durer en fait gère plutôt bien son
stress est là la qualité d'être très
efficace
en fait elle est pas trop centré sur
sur le
la technique ou la qualité technique
elle est vraiment centré sur
l'efficacité ça c'est une grande qualité
une qualité qui pourrait lui permettre
de gagner de nombreux titres
internationaux dans les prochaines
années et d'accomplir ses rêves golfique
j'avais beaucoup à gagner à l'evian
masters qui joue à evian et c'est un
temps d'un moment agréable c'est rentrer
dans les masters v c'est un beau tournoi
du pot c'est vrai que c'est un de mes
rêves et lis je loue s'envolera pour les
états unis au mois de janvier pour ses
études et pour continuer son
apprentissage du golf de haut niveau
elle devrait ensuite revenir en france
pour tenter de s'imposer sur le circuit
européen et pourquoi pas remporter un
titre du grand chelem
nous sommes de retour ici au golf
national de guyancourt avec paul
hermitage le directeur de la structure
est également avec alexandre hauw reyes
superintendant en charge du parcours
le golf de 50 ans nuit va accueillir la
ryder cup en 2018 créée en 1927 que
cette compétition oppose l'europe aux
états unis tous les deux ans elle
disputait alternativement aux usa et en
europe
pour faire simple c'est la plus grande
compétition golfique au monde
paul hermitage est ce que est ce que
vous êtes prêt tout simplement à trois
ans de du début de cet événement ben on
peut pas dire aujourd'hui qu'on est prêt
en est on est prêt dans la structure
dans l'organisation dans la logistique
dans notre organisation
on a les hommes les femmes en place ici
au golf national donc on sera prêt de
toute façon on n'a pas le droit d'être
en retard parce qu'on va pas changer la
date ou retardés pour nous ça c'est
clair mais oui tout à fait on est prêts
on va dire et quels sont les travaux du
coût qui reste à accomplir dans les
digues l'oise les le parcours loiselet
qui a été rénové il ya quelques jours
alors c'est pas le parcours de l'oise et
qui a été rénové c'est toute la
structure autour de l'eau adulé sur le
practice le club house les vestiaires
etc pour un meilleur service aux clients
pour un meilleur accueil
et ça ça fait partie d'un projet
immédiat pour nous amener jusqu'à la
ryder cup parce qu'on va avoir des
fermetures du parcours alejandro on
parlera tout de suite après mais on va
voir un fermeture de l'albatros à
compter de mi juillet de cette année
pendant neuf mois pour des gros gros
travaux de rénovation et de préparation
pour la ryder cup
et qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence à
les rendre aux dons le choix peut être
de ce parcours pour la ryder cup 2018
qu'est ce qui fait que les instances ont
choisi ce site à guyancourt bond baisse
qu'elle échoue à cette passion mais le
parcours c'était un organisme c'était la
fédération française de golf et
et avec la ville ddd barils à lyon paris
ciel à la commande est de saint quentin
en yvelines
disons que c'était l'endroit et après et
c'est vrai que les parcs où les
politiques de vider design que c'était
fini par couler et on l'appellait east
avion avec l'ailé raft autonome vous
possédez spectateurs les faits royaume
bas donc une très bonne visibilité des
lieux et le delliou les parcours est
doté de tout ce qu'il faut pour
accueillir une ride et le 4 mais aussi
et c'est tout le tour et c'est notamment
là la candidature présentée par la
fellation française et rock
donc vous pensez que l'albatros a fait
basculer à la candidature c'est ça oui
et il y aura combien de spectateurs du
cookie mais qui vont se déplacer
quotidiennement ici sur le sur le site
alors en termes de spectateurs
on va voir 70 mille personnes par jour
pendant cinq jours sur le site s'est pas
uniquement des spectateurs 1 on peut
compter à peu près peut-être dix mille
personnes autour de l'événement pour
organiser également les verts les
bénévoles pour l'organisation et c'est
donc on va tabler allez on va dire 60000
spectateurs par jour c'est énorme parce
que c'est le stade de france tout du
jour pendant cinq jours de suite
et si on rajoute ça et je dois le dire
aux mots parce que on n'est pas assez au
courant en france et justement si on
fait ce type d'émission c'est pour que
l'on fasse passer le message qu ici il
va avoir les jeux olympiques la coupe du
monde de foot mais pour le golf
mais pour tout le monde il faut que tout
le monde vit cette expérience en 2018
autour de nous à saint quentin en
yvelines parce qu'il va avoir cinq cent
vingt millions de téléspectateurs devant
leur écran pour regarder cet événement
et là on peut faire briller une région
non seulement un golf mais la france
entière si on peut comparer ça à un
sport c'est vraiment la coupe du monde
de foot fait pour le golf c'est ça c'est
ça tout à fait c'est la plus grande plus
grand événement planétaire de golf et
troisième événement mondial sportifs
médiatisés derrière la coupe du monde de
foot et les jeux olympiques et à
l'avenir enfin vous pensez que ce cette
compétition pourrait avoir lieu ici être
à nouveau organisé ou est-ce que ça va
être un événement qui va se faire une
fois et on va devoir attendre 50 ans
comme comme pour l'organisation de coupe
du monde par exemple oui je pense qu'il
ya un peu de ça je ne suis pas c'est
vraiment l'événement qu'il faut pas
monter voilà tout à fait c'est à dire
c'est un rendez vous je pense que dans
notre vie à nous peut-être on l'aura une
autre fois je n'en sais rien mais il
faut en profiter du fait que notre
candidature a été retenue qu'on a gagné
ça devant des allemands dans les
espagnols devant les portugais devant
les italiens qui ont tous candidate est
aussi il faut en profiter ça reviendra
pas très très vite donc vous encourage
et ouvrait à lire absolument s'y
intéressait au projet au moins découvrir
le golf d'ici 2018 et on invite tous les
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines à
venir n'auront visiter découvrir le golf
maintenant alejandro pour l'instant
l'europe et tenant du titre ça fait trop
d'édition qui remporte la ryder cup est
ce que vous pensez qu'en 2018 ça sera
plutôt l'europe ou les états unis où qui
est un grand spécialiste du golf
j espère que ça va là où l'on sait par
contre c'est pas ma ville mais ça serait
peut-être pas trop mal si en 2016 celle
times et c'est l'équipe américain qui
remporte là pour donner un petit peu
plus d'émotion à la compétition et que
l'équipe européenne pour la série de 18
et vous pensez que justement là
là l'europe ses chances face et vous
pensez que c'est l'europe vraiment qu'il
va active à 2000 et où est-ce parce
qu'on voit quand même pas mal de talent
émergent du côté les états unis ont
bondi pense que ça va être
certaines jouent en 2016 et parce que la
mêlée les américains m'ont avoué
et pas mal des sciences des deux
reprises l'arrêt vers 4 et
et au moins c'est clair que les rôles de
les capteurs américains et européens
s'arrêter sociale olala la compétition
en tout cas ça sera votre spectacle
paul c'est sûr c'est sûr je rejoins
complètement à l'air un drôle quand il
dit que on devrais pas le dire en
soutien l'europe
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une europe a
dominé un peu les matches depuis
depuis les dix dernières années les
américains sont un petit peu piqué au
vif dans leur fierté et on sent un
renouveau chez des joueurs américains
pour gagner ce trophée ce qui serait
bien pour les médias pour le public que
les américains gagnent chez eux en 2016
est ici ce serait juste énorme avec
soixante dix mille personnes dans la
large majorité qui sont des européens
qui hurle après des européens au golf
national dans notre pays pour un gain
europe ce qui d'ailleurs je vais juste
dire une chose c'est que ce qui est
magique dans la ryder cup de ce qu'on va
vivre ici c'est que c'est le seul sport
le golfe qui a une équipe européenne
si vous réfléchissez bien il n'y a pas
d'autres sports qui existent où il ya
une équipe europe et avec tout ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec pour ou contre
l'europe importe c'est le seul sport on
entend sur le fairway et 70000 personnes
qui crient europe peur europe toute la
journée et c'est ça qui est magique dans
la ryder cup également merci à vous deux
d'être intervenu sur cette émission
spéciale golf r c'est également nous
avons reçu ici à saint quentin en
yvelines sur ce golf national qui est
absolument magnifique vous souhaite bon
courage pour l'organisation de l'open de
france et pour la ryder cup 2018 est
donc on l'a bien compris vous n'allez
pas forcément bien dormir sur le trône
année pour préparer au mieux cette
compétition pour fermer cette émission
on termine sa part une date qui apparaît
à l'écran l'open de france est programmé
du 2 au 5 juillet ici sur le golf
national de guyancourt
et puis un golfeur donc de la planète
seront ici à saint quentin en yvelines
si vous voulez assister à ce grand
rendez vous il reste quelques places en
vente
c'est la fin de cette wii sport merci
d'avoir suivi passé une excellente
semaine sportive très bonne soirée sur
tv fil 78